I received a very interesting email from a
neuroscientist this week, and this neuroscientist
said, you know, David, you should just look
at the verbal symptoms of schizophrenia rather
than dementia or drug abuse to explain Donald
Trump's behavior.
And I want to dig right into this now.
Let me put the disclaimer right out there.
I am not a neuroscientist.
I am not coming up with any of this stuff.
And I am not diagnosing Trump with anything.
What I'm doing is pointing out we've been
looking at Trump's brain glitches.
His speech patterns, his bizarre behavior,
his walking away from his limo when it was
right in front of him, his not seeing Rudy
Giuliani, when Rudy Giuliani was right in
front of him, talking about the oranges of
an investigation.
Half Saffa hide all of that stuff.
Right.
We have heard from professionals who say it's
cognitive decline.
We've heard from professionals who say it's
dementia.
We've heard it could be a side effect of medication,
could be drug abuse.
A lot of different ideas.
A neuroscientist wrote to me and said, David,
look at the language disturbances that are
outlined in schizophrenia and just see what
you think.
So I did it.
Peer Review Journal article from this year.
Journal is called Current Opinions on Psychiatry.
The article is called Anomalies or Anomalies.
Both are valid pronunciations.
Anomalies in language is a biomarker for schizophrenia.
And it says that impaired verbal communication
is one of the key diagnostic features of schizophrenia
spectrum disorders.
And it lists the following traits.
And I have to tell you, Trump does seem to
experience every single one of these difficulties
with lexical selection and retrieval.
Trump has that issue, disturbances in priming
and reduced syntactic priming.
Trump has that reduced Proactiv inhibition
difficulties with coherant lead generating
a narrative.
Trump can't maintain a coherent narrative
when he speaks using neologisms word approximation,
disturbances in cohesion, vague references,
missing information and confused references.
It's like it's describing Trump speech sentences
with reduced syntactic complexity, less dependance
and embedded clauses and use fewer connective
markers.
That is Donald Trump's simplistic, childish
speech described to a T. Compared with normal
speech, the speech of those experiencing schizophrenia
contains more hesitations, pauses and longer
pauses.
That's Trump.
Intonation is flat and monotonous.
That is Trump.
We've actually talked about, you know, we
say when when Trump talks about the number
of deaths and cases and the tragedy and suffering
of Corona virus, we notice he seems to completely
lack empathy.
It also interpreted differently could be what
the biomarkers, the verbal biomarkers of schizophrenia
describe as a flat, monotonous intonation.
So I'm not bringing this to you as a diagnosis.
I am not coming up with this.
What I'm telling you, as a neuroscientist
pointed out.
Look at this.
Just take a look at it and see if it fits.
And boy, does it.
Let me know your thoughts.
We will take a quick break and follow up on
this very, very soon.